l'homme est plus puissant physiquement
la femme elle est plus en retrait c'est
comme ça maintenant on est dans une
modernité où maintenant les femmes
veulent avoir une paire de couilles mais
ça marche pas comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la marque 38600 euros
c'est comme ça ils vont pas s'empêcher
de faire plaisir à son fils parce que ça
coûte 38000 euros alors Benoît offrira
jamais mais ça me fait plaisir de ce
gamin soit le principe des parents vous
qui m'écoutez chez vous aussi
s'achètera des maisons à des millions et
des méchants
s'il pense que 38600 euros c'est un
cadeau il sort le soir il sera pas ce
que c'est que 20 euros 1000 euros 1200
euros donner la valeur des choses en
fait faut arrêter de dire que les riches
sont des gens mauvais non c'est pas ce
qu'on dit hein
vous dites forcément le gamin on en fait
un petit con pour dire les drogués les
machins les bijoux c'est pas vrai le
gamin il peut avoir une montre
excusez-moi je suis pas la marque au
poignet et être très gentil très
généreux et avoir les les bases de la
ville les bases de la vie ça se repose
pas sur une tu préfères je m'excuse je
préfère acheter une belle montre à ma
fille plutôt que de claquer dans des
conneries comme dans la drogue par
exemple ou des choses comme ça 40000 €
c'est ça bah dans 20 ans 40 000 € pour
lui c'est que dalle lui montre à 40000
pour donner à 200000
ce sont les propos polémiques de la
semaine et ils sont signés Vincent
Cassel dans une interview donnée au
journal britannique The Guardian
l'acteur français a choqué en déclarant
c'est presque honteux d'être un homme de
nos jours vous devez être plus féminin à
plus vulnérable mais écoutez si les
hommes deviennent trop vulnérables et
trop féminin je pense qu'il va y avoir
un problème ah non parce que je sais pas
moi je trouve que il y a il y a une
sorte de bon sens aussi parce que les
femmes en tout cas les femmes que j'ai
rencontré me demander une certaine
virilité c'est qu'elle voulait pas que
je leur ressemble comme moi je leur
demandais pas qu'elles aient les mêmes
goûts que moi que ça soit en terme de de
sortie de hobby de sport de choses qu'on
regarde à la télévision on a chacun
notre univers que chacun de sache ou pas
sa choquant qui se retrouve pas ou qui
est peu de liens de rencontres c'est pas
très grave parce que on se respecte un
look qu'on est amoureux et qu'on devine
belle histoire d'amour je vois pas
pourquoi on devrait épouser forcément
deviennent trop vulnérables et trop
féminin je pense qu'on aurait
véritablement un problème je pense que
tout simplement il donne son avis
d'hommes de son âge cette génération là
et il trouve que il y a peut-être un peu
de dérivent en ce moment il y a des
débats sur le sujet voilà maintenant je
peux comprendre qu'il est qu'il est son
avis
rebondis sur un personnage qui s'appelle
Andrew Tate qui est assez sulfureux
absolument c'est un personnage
extrêmement misogyne et qui l'expose de
façon très vulgaire et grossir sur les
réseaux et le problème c'est que Vincent
Cassel il le cite en disant qu'il ne dit
pas que des bêtises et là je pense qu'il
fait une grave erreur comme il l'avait
déjà fait en 2017 quand il avait joué
Gauguin et que Léa Salamé lui avait dit
que bon il jouait quand même un
personnage qui a des relations avec une
fille de 13 ans et il avait dit oui mais
à l'époque les filles de 13 ans c'était
pas vraiment les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui
là je travaille en ce moment même je
fais un film avec des des jeunes acteurs
je dirais pas leur nom mais je veux dire
ils apprennent à peine leur texte quoi
ils sont là en train d'avoir des
exigences personnelles ah non ça je fais
ça non ça je le fais pas
mais si vous vous comparez aux musiciens
vous vous pourriez acquérir un peu
d'humilité et de sens du travail et
d'excellence l'ambiance devait être top
sur le tournage donc il dit ça à la
sortie du film en promo qui sont
reconnus les gens qui sont que du coup
la maison parce que les vieux comme vous
dites les claviers et tout ils jouent
dans les films de jeunes qui sont pas
formatés et qui sont pas antipathiques
comme la bande à Fifi clavier juniaux
les vieux de la vieille ils jouent dans
ces films là et ça fait un tabac le
mélange entre en train de vivre à cause
du covid ce que la musique a vécu quand
il y a plus le CD et que les chanteurs
avaient plus d'argent le cinéma n'a plus
d'argent du tout je crois qu'il reste
actuellement sur vous dire de bêtises 3
ou 4 acteurs qui prennent un million
d'euros par film tous les autres
maintenant genre à l'envers l'avait dit
hein il prend 3 de sa colle 3 3 ou
400000 balles par film évidemment
c'était énorme mais à l'époque les mecs
prenaient des tonnes et des tonnes
[Musique]
il était des tensions provisoires il
devrait aller à Fresnes Fresnes qui est
une prison très vieille qui paraît-il
faut éviter et il y a des débats tous
les jours sur les quartiers VIP est-ce
que les people qui sont en VIP en fait
sont à l'hôtel contrairement aux autres
est-ce que c'est dur pas dur est-ce
qu'il y a une vitesse une justice à deux
vitesses le mieux c'est d'avoir bien
quelqu'un qui a fait 600 deux jours de
prison c'est Pierre Botton qui est avec
nous merci beaucoup déjà d'être là quand
on parle de quartier VIP on parle pas de
quartier VIP mais de quartier
vulnérables c'est ça oui vulnérable
alors le quartier dont on parle dans
tout le monde parle c'est à la santé la
santé c'est des étoiles où il y a quatre
bâtiments il y a un bâtiment qui
s'appelle le cube 4 dans laquelle deux
étages sont réservés aux arrivants
c'est-à-dire tout détenus qui arrivent
dans la prison se met dans le quartier
des arrivées en premier au deuxième et
en haut il y a 18 cellules 18 qui sont
18 cellules qui sont réservées aux
vulnérables aux personnes qui doivent
être isolées et aux gens qui sont
par là c'est VIP c'est des gens connus
je suis désolé de vous reprendre est-ce
que vous pensez qu'un violeur de
nourrisson est un VIP c'est ce que je
dis c'est un vulnérable
moi j'ai été avec un violon nourrisson
voilà donc c'est ce que je disais les
gens qui sont connus les deux femmes et
qui leur massacré la le visage à coup de
casse pour pas qu'il puisse se parler
pas derrière il circule plus de drogue
en prison que dans toutes les soirées
les rêves et les boîtes de nuit
parisienne
je raconte cette anecdote c'est que
l'été vous êtes obligé d'ouvrir parce
qu'il fait très chaud et que moi les
effluves de drogue qui remontaient de
des fenêtres à côté puisque j'étais au
dernier étage était tel que je me suis
senti
des gens cannabis et tout ça c'est il y
a pas de drogue genre je prends lui les
drogues de synthèse il y a tout ce que
vous voulez mais non il y a tout ce que
vous voulez